[ Knock on door ]
-Come on in.
Hey, Orlando.
-Hey, Jimmy.
How are you, man?
-I'm doing great, man.
I'm just working on one of those
"Me, Also Me" tweets.
-What's that mean?
-It's a thing people do
on Twitter where
you say a thing about you
and then another thing
also about you
that undermines the first thing
in a humorous way.
For example, me, I'm on a diet.
Also me,
ketchup is a vegetable, right?
-Oh. Right.
So like, me, my TV show
"Carnival Row" is out now.
Also me, my movie "The Outpost"
is coming out soon.
-Mm, no, no, no.
More like, me, "Ugh!
The summer is too hot.
Also me, "Ugh!
The winter is too cold."
-Ah, right. So me, I played a
sexy elf in "Lord of the Rings."
Also me,
I played the sexy pirate
in "Pirates of the Caribbean,"
right?
-No. Me, I'm a sophisticated,
mature adult.
Also me, I wish they showed
Saturday-morning cartoons
all of the other days
and times, too.
-Me, I'm engaged to Katy Perry.
Also me, Katy Perry
is beautiful, and I love her.
-Me, I hate it when people are
inconsiderate at the workplace.
Also me, does anybody mind if I
reheat my fish in the microwave?
-Me, I'm a goodwill ambassador
for the charity organization
UNICEF.
Also me, UNICEF does important
work in over 190 countries
to save the lives of children.
-No, no, no, no, no!
Look!
It's me, I'm trying
to look at my phone less!
Also me, "Oh, look! I just got
a new follower on Instagram!"
-I get it.
Me, I like pizza.
Also me, pizza tastes good.
[ Laughter ]
Did I do it right?
-Sure.
[ Cheers and applause ]